in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast if you are a
first-time listener you're in for a
treat
you think we're gel Rogan huh
you think we're uh who else is very
credible in the space personally uh
right into Oh Chris D'Elia
come on now I heard he's your best
friend and you guys I do not what you
guys like the children I'm a fan this
episode is called Nick's in her thoughts
the last time Nick was on here he was
talking a little bit about the Pope's in
the Catholic Church
Oh is he like watching documentaries of
what they do that's true
the latest one that I saw was the
Jeffrey Epstein documentary have you
guys watched it I watched two episodes
dude it's it's really dark and it's
really [ __ ] but I feel like everybody
needs to watch that documentary is like
what's called rape documentaries know
what that other one where that guy [ __ ]
the in all the generations in the tree
or whatever it well because it's so
crazy
it's so [ __ ] nuts to hear about these
things and then like you hear about how
Jeffrey Epstein just got away with it
for his whole entire life and had
everybody in his [ __ ] pocket dude he
paid off the police department in Miami
a hundred thousand dollars like oh
here's the donation and nobody would
investigate the [ __ ] he was doing well
and he works if you give me somebody
okay let me ask you something what's up
all right so you're a cop okay your name
is officer Dunn okay all right your name
is officer Dunn yeah
Jeffery up somebody reports Jeffrey
Epstein right Epstein how's that I have
no idea
Jeffrey Faustine I saw so he comes in
guy he goes hey I'm here to arrest you
that's funny
I have four hundred thousand dollars are
you going to arrest me would you arrest
him or no well in the context of what he
was doing yeah that's a good person
because bro he was he was trafficking
like 16 year old girl
fifteen year old girls and this is what
he would do he would make them come to
his house and be like hey do you wanna
like do you want to make some money
giving people massages and they'd be
like okay of course exactly and they're
there 15 and here we get other
fifteen-year-old girls to get other
fifteen-year-old girls and they would
bring them to his house and he'd be like
all right he'll get naked they'll start
massaging him for like a minute and then
he'll you know the rest is history
weirdest part of that document I only
watched a couple of episodes and the
weird part was kind of how they
described how it would happen
yeah and it's it's like a 1980s like
creepy movie right so first it was a
lady that was involved with with with
Jeffrey either his wife or his
girlfriend and she's still out and about
yeah she would just massage day it's
okay don't worry about it just just go
ahead and fall into it it's like what
the [ __ ] let me write the script the
terrible script yeah and the girls would
just cry and she would just go about her
way and then nothing would happen to
them their money is so powerful people
have no idea like it doesn't matter who
you are as long as you have a lot of
[ __ ] money you're almost untouchable
oh yeah and that's what happened and not
only didn't even a lot of money but he
would get other celebrities or other
people the power to indulge in these
services that are highly illegal
and then he would film them and he has a
lot of pretty much he has blackmail on
all these people that's why a lot of it
I heard that he was like they were even
thinking that he was like intelligence
for another country and apparently he
like that's that's what they were saying
about him but like they would show his
back room his house and it was just TV
monitors in every room every bathroom
and do they know about the recordings or
he just did it just to have evidence I I
heard that well one of the theories I
heard was that he would like kind of
invite politicians powerful people and
print some of them knowing those
probably weren't new we're into like
little kids and [ __ ] and others he was
probably like hey there's girls here
they would have sex with girls he'd film
them and then he'd be like hey by the
way that quote was 16 and I haven't
recorded
oh sure you're gonna do what the [ __ ] I
want you to do or for whoever more
they're all [ __ ] little molester you
name some of that too but that's the
thing is like that's what's really scary
because this documentary focuses on just
him but there's like a net
of creepy [ __ ] the here's the piece of
he was there's a lot of weird [ __ ] like
that going on it's kind of crazy how
much he bullshitted his way up the
ladder yeah cuz he didn't graduate from
college either yeah he did he didn't
graduate he committed a bunch of fraud
apparently he was stealing money do you
remember the the store the limited the
limited - yeah yeah yeah remember those
stores and I guess he was in business
with a guy that sold that chain and that
franchised
for like billions of dollars that was a
billionaire and I guess what he was
doing he's a hedge fund manager I don't
know what the [ __ ] that means what the
[ __ ] exactly but apparently he was he
stole about like 40 million dollars from
this dude and he didn't even know until
afterwards right allegedly he didn't
know yeah and and then he bought a
Island with his house like this mansion
on it and that's where he would fly out
like all these people of power
I guess celebrities Bill Clinton would
go yeah every bro Bill Clinton coming
like it was a dream like 28 times or
something yeah it was on the flight logs
all this stuff 128 that's a lot of times
[Laughter]
you know cuz if you went like maybe
twice they listen I just went out there
just go check it out yeah how did you go
228 I think was 28 I don't know I don't
know who's 28 28 is a lot of foots a lot
to go check out the island [ __ ] what he
was doing dude what are you talking
about of course he did and then on top
of that it's like all the girls that he
was hanging out with we're all like they
they would show pictures of them when
they were more people like up in arms
about that [ __ ] if they know that Bill
Clinton was going to this people were
freaking out for a while but it's it's a
cycle do you exactly say age we live in
like something crazy will happen and
it'll be big news and then something
else crazy happens and it kind of just
social media it just kind of like
filters its way out coronavirus came at
the rotavirus and condoms and then you
know it just always something new crazy
happen and but it wasn't really covered
in mainstream media
yeah no I'm talking about well but it's
the most obvious they killed this dude
story you
you know are you familiar with Alex
Jones yeah so maybe my buddies are
really into the stuff he says and a lot
of the times I'm like dude shut the [ __ ]
up what are you talking about and they
were always trying to convince me of
pizza gate do you know what pizza gate
was no apparently it's like people in
the White House or like in Hollywood or
whatever just higher-ups in general
they're all connected and they would
just have human trafficking like teenage
girls come to the White House apparently
and have sex with all these politicians
and the white yea parently that's that's
what the story is yeah I used to tell
this dude like yo you're [ __ ] full of
[ __ ] like what are you talking about
that's nuts right as soon as I finished
seeing this documentary and seeing how
many ties of Jeffrey Epstein was with
all these people on affidavits and legal
documents and also when uh when all the
black lives matter stuff was happening
when anonymous released all these
information I think one of them was the
affidavit from Donald Trump
and Jeffrey Epstein and on there there's
all these cases of specific cases of all
these girls talking about how Donald
Trump like raped these girls you know
and was involved in human trafficking
all this stuff could you imagine what
it's like to be touched by Donald Trump
dark that dude it is disgusting they
have some footage of them together like
at a nightclub and it's like a news it's
like CNN or some [ __ ] but this is like
back in the 90s yeah and they're filming
them and they're like he's like you
could hear him mouthing like oh she's
pretty cute what about her over there
yeah yeah damn these dudes are rapists
Balestra they have any laws of Donald
Trump going to that island I don't so I
mean I wouldn't be surprised I did I
think they I don't know if they have
like he's off a legal document on an
affidavit yeah I saw that Jeffrey
Epstein talking about how he was how
much you want to bet [ __ ] Donald Trump
got Epstein killed I wouldn't be
surprised I would not be surprised that
I bet a lot of people wanted that fool
dead because I bet he was he was willing
to make a deal
I thought was him though when I went
yeah when he when I went to jail before
I went to jail I would have just
released all the footage yes why the
[ __ ] wouldn't you do that I don't know
yeah I don't know why yeah you know he
he should have known that he was gonna
die
Yeah right like for effect might maybe
he felt like there was a way out for him
because he had that leverage or
something but no yeah there's also the
fact you're right he should have
released he's probably just a [ __ ]
sociopath and he thinks he's like I'll
be fine another conspiracy theory that
like it was just so that he didn't
really die they just act like he died
and then he they just released him he
got out but that's like we're getting in
there that's another I should but it's a
juicy one about Hitler they think he was
in like Argentina or like or like Chile
or something Hitler some people believe
that Hitler's still alive because he he
faked his death and he went to Argentina
iceworm people where he would hate
looking at them not Argentina or like
Chile or something yeah cuz Argentinians
are light-skinned there maybe they have
a huge like German population over there
now and it's like all of it is very like
Nazi style architecture and things like
that it's crazy that's that's what the
Tim Kennedy has a show on the History
Channel where he goes and he searches
for Hitler in Argentina
what do you work Nick hey you were not
when I go hey bills when I go when I go
for like when I do my cardio when I go
for runs I put in my headphones and I
listen to all the stuff I wonder how
many pays bills sometimes okay I
calculated all the hours of
documentaries you've watched so far
you've only slept two hours and you've
never worked at all hey so what the buzz
is what happens when means if we deep
dive on the stuff oh yeah we go deep bro
we're deep on the Jeffrey Epstein stuff
it's gonna kill himself bro there's
money how involved in this [ __ ] but when
I ask him just do simple stuff for his
own business he goes I'm gonna post like
work out there looking annoying because
he'll say some of the stupidest [ __ ] to
me like I I've told him like this is I
first met him two years ago what to do
just yesterday he goes you know what I
need to do man I need to start doing
online coaching you bitch-made
[ __ ] I told you that for the
past two years I was like David have you
heard this thing called Instagram where
you could post stuff and people will
follow you and they'll
like all your stuff and he tells me as
if I haven't told him that before and I
want to slice his throat right now I can
do it bro Jeff I swear to God
okay do it bro bring it what could do it
I'm gonna throw it up anyway
but hottest news right now and it's so
funny because right to the segue man
behind the Jeffery is hottest news right
now Chris mother [ __ ] D'Elia
now I have no ties this man no
connection whatsoever never spoke to the
dude Ali no people who know who are
friends with him I will say this I know
nothing about him but the man looks a
little rapey close next time well you
know more about it obviously since you
don't work [ __ ] strings attached to
him hostess with the red line Matthew
McConaughey and true detective Keystone
Light well Chris D'Elia has been in a
lot of hot water obviously every single
like comic out there who knows him who
knows of him has been like putting out
their opinion about the situation which
I always found very odd because if I
don't know I guess if you're like a
really close friend of his I don't know
why it's so pertinent for you to go out
and just start telling your opinion
about the situation right
seems to me very opportunistic but I
don't know how Hollywood works cuz
obviously I'm not a part of it but yeah
yeah let me tell you some Mouse I'm too
honest to be a part of Hollywood my [ __ ]
out there publicly but uh something
leaked some okay so there was a young 16
year old girl at the time that put up
this tweet about him about how he's a
perv or whatever and that [ __ ] just
started to go viral and basically what
she was saying is that he was
quote-unquote like grooming her or
soliciting her for sex no
or knowing that she was a sixteen year
old and from then on all these other
people started releasing stuff about him
and their interactions with him which I
read a couple of things and some of them
were kind of odd because number one [ __ ]
it I don't have to do disclaimer it was
really funny because some these were
like twenty five night when I was 23 yes
then they came out to me and he had the
story and she's talking about oh yeah he
was she tried to pick me with this
sleazy pickup line and it was so [ __ ]
gross and I'm like and you tried to are
you trying to say this is a me-too
situation where you try to pick you up
at a bar yeah I'm like next move on and
I hate that [ __ ] because if this girl
did get solicited for sex as a 16 year
old girl
it makes her story look like because you
keep on bringing out your [ __ ]
stories like what the [ __ ] is this
that's the problem is that like the
false but the people that are faking the
funk [ __ ] up the real acting diminishes
the actual movement and it's like what
the [ __ ] don't muddy the waters you know
any media somebody's girls I just want
to tell em to shut the [ __ ] up like your
story doesn't count right now what's up
that date is what you're saying right
now is very reasonable
is it super reasonable and logical and
logical yes the word logical but because
you say that people will just back
you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and it's
like Ben there's no dialogue the money
thing is I'm not miss I'm on the I'm on
the female side right now I'm saying
that this woman is a piece of [ __ ]
because she's taking away the power from
the original girls story which first
their story if it's true she'd be taken
very seriously yeah absolutely
when you talk about a bad date that you
had with Chris D'Elia and you got creepy
vibe from him it's like are you just
what why did you put that out what does
that do it doesn't it doesn't get offer
any damning evidence it doesn't make him
look terrible it makes you look it makes
you look terrible makes you look like
the person that's doing this for
quote-unquote attention because you were
not 16 you were 23 years old he didn't
what he did he drugged you he uh did he
coerced you into something was he
physical with you or was it and it's
just a story about a terrible date with
a sleazy guy right yeah and I'm like
that sucks that you went on a sleazy
date with a sleazy guy I understand but
we're talking about a girl who was
solicited for sex at 16 yeah so let's
not talk about that mean you could talk
about that on your blog on xanga
[Applause]
this episode is brought to you by they
type in xanga calm nothing pops up y'all
I used to write my feelings on servant I
bought the company and deleted
everything I was trying to sign sign
back into my xanga right so I could see
my feelings so you delete everything it
was all gone give it give us a little
sneak peek of like what it was what were
you writing about it's basically all my
vlogs because I was 13 like Aaron's a
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate her
I would be writing some [ __ ] I've been
talking mad [ __ ] about like some of my
personal friends too because they pissed
me off that day cuz I would use it as a
journal but the funny thing about men is
that especially I think when I was
younger having a journal was as we used
to say back in the day forgot II a
little guy and so we would say like yo I
forgot YZ would write journals and laws
but then at the same time we're over
here on xanga writing our [ __ ] raps
hopefully we get found [ __ ] listen I'm
on xanga you ain't want to [ __ ] with me
because I'm a bank thinking you know
what people need to hear this yeah I
hate hot pockets do you know that like
that's actually what got you famous on
YouTube was everyone's anger well is
yours anger I remember a really popular
Isaiah back in the day was girls who
would used to write poetry oh my god
dude I had a girl one time in middle
school she's like you know when you had
crushes in middle school and stuff like
that we like she was like liked me or
something like that and I like you too
but I was like scared like I didn't know
how to interact with girls I would just
avoid her and then she called me one day
and she was like I wrote you a poem and
she was like already like I picked up
the phone she's like already like about
to cry and then she read me this poem
and I was sitting outside on my deck
like thank you for that and was like
that was the weirdest [ __ ] thing bro
this because it has girls riding him
poems it was middle school
matter bro doesn't matter I've never had
a single girl at home / I once opened up
a napkin from a girl and they said [ __ ]
you who's this and it was the teacher
[Laughter]
you can't prove who was nice with Taos
key scroll [ __ ] you you were saying some
interesting stuff about the whole
situation because a lot of new
information came out about the girl who
originally put the the tweet out yeah so
the first I thought it was odd because
whenever I don't know it's people like
to jump to conclusions a little bit
because this stuff is it's a very
sensitive topic for sure right it's like
when you accuse somebody of being a
pedophile that comes with a lot like
it's you know you want to make sure it's
like the worst thing that you could yeah
like you want to make sure this stuff is
confirmed or overwrite but when the
allegations are out you read the
messages and the proof that this lady
presented this girl presented it's
pretty damning yeah yeah it's it's
damning but it's also the first I think
it was like the first girl that dead
that put it out it just was like you
know you tell Chris was kind of like
being a creep and let's make out and
he's asking her if you want to hang out
but it seemed very like normal can I
just say this for people who don't know
you should already know if regular
people go into other people's DMS and
they hit they hit on them all the time
could you imagine how much celebrities
do this [ __ ] yeah because they
understand what they can do with their
quote unquote power of course or what
they can do with their fandom like their
reach is so much Sarge bigger of course
but continue but uh yeah the the first
initial messages it was just like hey
what are you doing tonight you want to
come hang out bah blah you know and that
was her proof for saying he groomed me
as a 16 year old yada yada yada but
there's also there's no pretense of like
how old he knew that she was and
apparently she didn't he didn't know
according to him and all the stuff that
he released and I guess he really stood
a couple days ago like his legal team
released it or something but and then
there was another there was an exchange
where they were talking and she says oh
you're seven
and he goes oh well you're too young
sorry I thought you were 18 like you
came to my show yeah you have to be 18
to come in the show sorry my bad bye and
also they had that conversation one
comment that was from actually from a
different girl okay and then the first
drawer that released everything you know
it was just like they never they never
met up apparently so she was saying he
solicited me for nudes and then I guess
she sent him like a picture of a panda
or something to like be funny or
whatever yeah and then after that I
guess the conversation ended you know
and then the new evidence that came out
was an email saying from her asking him
saying hey I'm 21 now I'm DTF and it was
like word-for-word and oh she wrote that
you wrote about the original things yeah
what I'm 21 now I'm DTF and I guess
there was no response which doesn't
still but that doesn't make it okay to
hit up does a young girl but if she's
painting the picture of like this dude
was just a complete creep who likes
listen to me Bubba and then four years
later you're like hey let's [ __ ] right
now it's kind of like because she was
painting this image that it was like all
him being you know but still not cool
but it does its information yeah that's
the thing it's like if you're gonna if
you have evidence on somebody it's like
you should be able to you know post all
of it right because it's put the whole
story out there
yeah because cuz the logic behind that
is this I guess from what I'm seeing
from my perspective is if if this woman
went out of her way right to say that
this guy is a creep he was trying to
groom me when I was younger but then for
you so he ignores you for three or four
years and then out of doors you go
hey I'm 21 now I'm down to [ __ ] now it
puts on this the the shift of
responsibility to the girl down yeah
yeah it's like now now there's a little
bit of responsibility on your part there
because if he was grooming you or
whatever but he didn't keep in contact
to you for X amount of years but then
you know lo and behold you were ignored
and then you said I'm down to [ __ ] ya
and he didn't [ __ ] you right it's like
wait what what what is the basis of your
argument now yeah are you saying that
you didn't want him and he kept on
pressing you yeah but then you
approached him and said you wanted to
[ __ ] him
yeah so this is where it goes into that
conversation where people are having
online I'm not having this conversation
honestly with this whole crystalline
thing I I don't know him so I don't give
a [ __ ] about him you know whatever
happens to him
yeah but for in this situation there's
conversation of you know people had this
talk of do when it girls like 17 or 18
years old does she know what's going on
right because that's what I've been
reading a lot of these comments on
Twitter the Liz that that's the main
argument right it's like when I was 16
or something if I wanted to [ __ ] a
celebrity or an old a guide like I would
do whatever I can to [ __ ] them like I
wanted I wanted to [ __ ] but obviously
the responsibility goes in the adult to
be like hey you're a child you don't
know what you're doing exactly it's not
this right so that word that responsibly
goes on Chris D'Elia and he doesn't get
excused from that behavior but also just
to mention just to just to go back to
that is see there is a response but that
girl if she if her intentions were to
[ __ ] him right yeah it's not the story
of her painting it out to him soliciting
her yeah for for whatever sex right
exactly it was you were soliciting him
the other way or there was mutual in
that type of sense right Chris D'Elia is
still wrong for it but you exactly right
and some of the stuff is like it seems
mutual on the outside from just like
what is shown right but a lot of times
too it's like from what that girl did I
guess the first chick it seems like it's
cherry picking right it's cherry picking
you didn't show the whole - she didn't
show the message where she says hey by
the way I'm 21 I'm down exactly right
but there's also other things where it
is a little creepy there was a red one
where he was hitting up this girl and I
guess she was like oh I'm 17 right and
then he goes oh sorry too young and then
stopped talking to her
he literally in DM her a year from that
date like a year in like a couple of
days and was like hey what's up that's
crazy it's creepy but it's not against
the law not actually but see that's
what's that's what that's why that that
fetish if you have like an 18 like yeah
that is just so creepy because they are
it's it's it's a because it's like I'm
almost a pedophile part of the you know
that which is weird but you're right
it's not only it's a weird line 18 like
what's the what's what's why is that
such a special because you is because he
watched too much [ __ ] porn and every
time you look on porn as a girl says 18
year old you know she's 36 you're a 36
year old woman and
that's like a category like barely legal
well yeah I'd like what's creepier than
saying barely legal man like it's so
[ __ ] kind of weird just barely legal
this goes to that conversation
[Laughter]
this goes to the conversation of the
whole louis c.k thing right when louis
c.k was you know masturbating it is
really asking some a girl it's like can
i jack off in front of you and then that
they people got upset about that because
of their saying that these male
celebrities are using their power and
their influence to kind of hold these
people that hostage right right and i
think people are just kind of tapping
into that mentality of this is a
celebrity he's willingly knowing that
he's a celebrity and he has a certain
amount of leverage with his girls so if
he does want to have sex when he can't
whether the underage or not yeah and the
weird thing is is I don't think the way
he looks helps about at all no no yeah
he's like looks like a douchebag yeah I
mean looks creepy and people were saying
this dude was like using nudes that
these girls would send him to like
blackmail these chicks you know I mean
oh really
there's like what the see that's the
other thing though too is like there's a
lot of other stuff that comes out but
people are focusing on the pedophilia
side but there's all these other women
that are like my whole thing is my idea
is like whether smoke there's fire
yeah right if Jeffrey Epstein wasn't
[ __ ] human trafficking chicks they
wouldn't be able to make multiple
documentaries a [ __ ] high part hours
through your documentary on how he was
right in a percent and if there's like
20 probably more than that I saw like a
gang right it was like maybe like 30 or
40 people coming out talking about like
their experience of them a lot of them a
good amount of them were like [ __ ]
but then a lot of them were like this is
problematic right and and even from the
statement that he released I'm talking
about like you know I apologize you know
I'm trying to be this man anymore yada
yada yada you know like that's one thing
but some of the stuff that like came out
whether you want to believe it or not
it's up to the reader right but at the
same time it just things like just super
disrespectful these chicks like you'll
invite this chick to come over have sex
doors like five minutes
all right like kind of get out it's like
things like that and you know whether
you think that's right or not that's on
you right I mean I hear so many weird
stories about celebrities and I don't I
don't know if it's true or true or not
like I heard the story about [ __ ]
Justin Bieber how Justin Bieber would he
would bring girls to his place had them
go up to his room and because he now
he's a born-again Christian right so his
wings his wings are out he's he married
this is before he got married to was it
one of the Baldwin's daughters or some
[ __ ] like that I don't have like Baldwin
is out or some [ __ ] I could be making
[ __ ] up Doug Baldwin one of the cousins
no but he would have them sit down kneel
in front of him and pray for their hell
yeah and he would ask them if they have
accepted Lord the Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ into their life that's what's up
right and if she said yes they would
[ __ ] that's crazy and so I heard this
respected though you know and I heard
this from somebody who at the time I
used to work for a travel visa company
right so whenever he wanted to go travel
somewhere else to do a concert he had to
get a visa for or whatever and um she
would sit there and he would he would
make her sit and wait until he was done
[ __ ] this girl and this is like her
hearing this ship watching this like
model chick go up and he would pray for
her soul asking her she's telling tell
her about Jesus Christ and then [ __ ] her
and then make her wait there the whole
time and then sign the papers and never
leave Wow Wow
yeah so you know this is it's a
different world right it's a different
world I mean it's kind of weird that
he's like are you a Christian no okay
I'm still have this doesn't make him a
creep it's just really weird it's just
we get really [ __ ] weird you think
about like a dude like Justin Bieber
who's been famous since he was 13
whatever the feel a bit like his whole
he's never had a normal child
that dude is out of his mind 100% so
something like that doesn't surprise me
well although a lot of those [ __ ] are
weirdo [ __ ] and then you give them that
little edge of power like yeah
and humans don't do well with power at
all and it's so easily a corrupted
you have to constantly be checked so if
you've just been running rampant then
why wouldn't you [ __ ] be like let's
pray our Father and then I put my dick
in your butt especially like Justin
Bieber bro like out of all the stars in
the past like 10 years he's probably one
like top 5 biggest stars of all time in
the past 10 years right weird comments I
used to get to people like well here's
like Oh some people are gonna be very
careful about saying talking about the
stuff so they don't get [ __ ] on them
it's like well first of all what the
[ __ ] are you doing man yeah exactly what
are you doing like I have no problem
saying this [ __ ] because you can look
through all my DMS and the only thing I
talked to about random women is hey
what's the recipe for that food you play
that's it come to you for advice or
something exactly I got nothing you
could try to dig [ __ ] on me I got
nothing women don't like me even when I
tried this podcast is brought to you by
a rake on my friends do you have earbuds
with strings and wires attached to them
what are you thinking do you also poop
in a hole in the ground I bet you use a
toilet because that is the
technologically advanced way of doing
things when you go poopie well the same
thing goes for your ear buds and your
comfort I have used ear buds without
wires specifically my Rea cons for quite
a while now I use it when I jog I use it
when I workout when I hit a bag whenever
I need to listen to a podcast on my six
to seven mile walks my rake on earbuds
are the ones that come with me that's it
earbuds
I meant earbuds well here's a few facts
for you guys just to keep you guys
enticed and interested into the earbuds
that I use rake on wireless earbuds by
the way
start off at about half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market and they sound just as amazing as
other top audio brands you know I use
them they sound great their newest model
the everyday e 25-year buds are the best
ones yet with six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass any
more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit and that for me
is very important I
hate road noise when I'm walking outside
specifically because I live in the city
and in the city there's a lot of road
noise and it's just enough so I could
hear for my dangers but I don't want to
hear honking constantly when I'm trying
to listen to my genius brain pod cast so
check it out now's the time to get the
latest and greatest from Ray Khan get
15% off your order at buy rake on.com
slash brain that's buy rake on Comm
slash brain for 15% off rake on wireless
earbuds buy rake on Comm slash brain
about me right now they said well David
so had a harem of women that he used to
[ __ ] the first thing people would say is
yeah right no I did I meet two people
they're like okay what power you drove a
Honda Element for four years watch that
oh my god dude it's like my flip flops
and socks so that's why you do that I
see your tracks baby that's right that's
why Muriel's trust me she's like barely
watch you yeah life is great
our ladies have a lot in common yeah
[ __ ] dude I talk to men come on man let
me solicit that PEP there's a lot of
people doing weird [ __ ] man
there's a lot of [ __ ] whatever kinks you
have I guess but at the same time it's
uh but see this part of the problem too
is that like it's nice that we can stay
here and have a conversation about this
this is what we should be doing a
conversation but on social media [ __ ] is
just all about outrage or like about
like there's no real conversations
happening it's either black or white
you're on a team if you even try to get
nuanced you're instantly a [ __ ] hero
you're Satan himself you know what I
mean yeah so that's part of the issue
too whether Chris D'Elia did this [ __ ]
or not if you did it obviously that's
[ __ ] up and that's weird but there
should still be due process and we
should still have nuanced thinking and
be able to have a dialogue because
that's really always ultimately the
solution and it's not just what Chris
D'Elia but even with like all the George
Floyd stuff everything happening like
there's a lot of right obviously black
lives matter clearly
yeah dude yes who the [ __ ] if you argue
against black people mattering you're an
idiot
right but like we still need to be able
to to talk you know like we still have
to have dialogue and that's that's
that's what scares me the most about all
these situations is that it's like one
[ __ ] thing after another of just
outrage and just boom boom boom or if
you don't agree with this and you're a
piece of [ __ ] bah-bah-bah and there's no
[ __ ] it's like cuz we're like in the
country like we're in a big relationship
right and if you just immediately your
partner we can't break up with each
other
we're here we're in this [ __ ]
relationship if you just shun you're
your girlfriend out or your boyfriend
out like that's obviously not the way to
have a healthy relationship you hate
each other you have to [ __ ] sit down
and talk to each other I mean the hard
part is like the conversation part is
hard to have because I think from the
perspective of like the black
community's like we've been trying to
have this conversation for so [ __ ]
long oh right and now it's like I'm
tired of tired of having to explain to
people what this feels like even if you
see video like damning evidence of this
video of George Floyd right yeah the
first thing I said when George Floyd was
murdered was I guarantee you tomorrow
there's gonna be a article about his
past right and they said George Floyd
when he like ten years ago
held a pregnant woman at gunpoint he had
he was they didn't even ask if she
deserved that's a joke but but that's
but this is what happens right I was
joking but see this is the stuff that
happens right and so because like that
conversation is so hard to have because
no matter what there's always a reason
right and you know people are finding
this case of this kid Elisha McCain
Elisha McCain there's not a single ounce
of evidence that you could find against
this kid now it's hard for people to be
like oh but what was his past like but
people are still gonna [ __ ] do it
yeah and that's the cipher and the thing
is they look at that situation and they
still find something right they go well
if he wasn't flailing his arms this kid
who was on the [ __ ] spectrum who was
walking home with a ski mask on in
Colorado of all [ __ ] places yeah oh
my god my bad ski [ __ ] state you know
anybody had a ski mask god forbid yeah
he bought negative 13 degrees slamming
to the floor for three to four cops
way down on him he's a hundred and forty
[ __ ] pounds he's screaming for his
[ __ ] life throws up popping full of
ketamine for like a 220 pound male 140
pounds and he dies these cops are not in
jail right the paramedic is not on
trouble the EMT or whatever is also not
in trouble as well so and then there's
still people who say but so this is why
that conversation is hard to have so
even worse the evidence is so [ __ ]
clear people want to be like let's
discuss this there's there is no there
is no medium ground for whether racism
is right or wrong
yeah so that's why the conversation is
hard to have I think like that
conversation is easier to have for
people like you because you're also open
minded right a lot of people I think
like open minded people are easy to have
a conversation with but I don't think
that reflects a majority of the people
in this world and we see that in social
media is so often Facebook Twitter
whatever people say some of the dumbest
[ __ ] on Twitter like it Twitter annoys
me so much that I enjoy watching it like
I do it I enjoy reading the [ __ ] yeah
yeah right I don't know how many times I
read something unpopular opinion and
it's not even an unpopular opinion just
so they could get likes they go
unpopular opinion water hydrates you
they're like oh my god it's like I just
sliced you at your kneecaps yeah so and
it's also like the other side like
people will say crazy stuff crazy stuff
that deserved to be checked and there's
still a community of people that are
like oh my god I totally agree whatever
you're saying yeah I'm going back to
like the Chris D'Elia stuff with all the
stuff that came out it was because I saw
it like right somebody text me was i yo
look up crystally on twitter so i looked
it up and it was just happening at the
moment and it was just so crazy whether
he's guilty or not right it was just
crazy to see how many people were just
jumping down this guy's throat you know
and that happens all the time
like whoever right but at the same time
it was just crazy to see whether you
agree with it or not it was just wild to
see all these different people come out
talk about his comedy and you know Chris
Delia's situation too also goes in that
same breadth of women being very tired
of the [ __ ] right because that's not
that they have definitely they
constantly have to go through this every
day like when they are sexually
assaulted when they're raped something
happens to them and a lot of times
nobody [ __ ] believes them and nobody
[ __ ]
that means it's because of what they
wore because of what they had and they
have to keep on saying it doesn't matter
what the [ __ ] I wear or not like you
have no right to my body Yeah right so
because they had to keep on doing this
repetitiously this is where that anger
and that fervour comes it's not from
something that happens overnight
it's something that they had a store in
for a very very [ __ ] years and
hundreds of years of resentment the
anger is super justifiable I think it's
it's right yeah I get it you're [ __ ]
pissed you're like [ __ ] this I'm tired
like you said with the black community
explaining that and no one listening
like what the [ __ ] how long have we been
hearing about this [ __ ] and nothing's
happened you know but I think part of
the problem is is I think they're right
I I mean I think that like obviously
racist there is no black or white when
it comes to racism racism is [ __ ]
wrong yeah there's no in-between on that
issue and the in and of itself but the
problem is is that we get on these
[ __ ] teams yeah and it's like it's
like when you like it I always relate it
back to a relationship because I've had
girlfriends were like like especially
the bad relationships were like you you
have all this like baggage in the
relationship where like you sure pissed
about something that happened [ __ ]
three months ago or whatever and you
guys get in an argument about something
else but like and you kind of know she's
right but because you're like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] like I will disagree til the end
like and you now you know you're wrong
but like I'm still just gonna fight you
because you were wrong about this thing
twenty-year whatever you know yeah
there's like a lot of that just like
baggage [ __ ] arguments happening
where like people are not not I'm not
saying like for the people that are like
on the conservative side yeah like they
just don't want to agree with anything
that's liberal yeah even though exact a
lot of conservatives there's probably
people and that are like middle
conservatives that agree that like
police brutality is a problem and there
is racism um they're not all [ __ ]
racist and they want to some of them I'm
sure want to but then they hear some
other crazy [ __ ] that comes to the left
and they're they associate like if I
agree with this then that means I'm
agreeing with that and it just becomes
too much of the team like there's just
no yeah a lot of them no missed
opportunities right and I and I do
understand to where some people have
this issue of like well when we kind of
attack this these type of topics with a
lot of rage and anger there's a lot of
missed opportunity for communication so
talk to these people and there's people
who want to learn and you just already
automatically say well like you're not
on my side [ __ ] you right he's already
lost them exactly
you know exactly so those missed
opportunities are very sad and I and I
get that too cuz sometimes when I see
people who I believe have to get flamed
because once you start taking away some
[ __ ] from them then they go oh this
might be a problem yeah because many
times before people have gotten away
with their shitty behavior so many times
yeah till they got flamed because even
Krystal his case right so Chris D'Elia
let's say let's say he's the biggest
creeper on earth right and then you have
a bunch of friends who were around you
who listened to these stories that he
does and they just laugh they go hahaha
whatever that's a really dope story so
you [ __ ] this girl then you come in
there I then you kicked around the
middle of the street and they're like
that's a great stand-up set move on yeah
right now you take away their friends
and it's just him telling a story to a
bunch of strangers it's like that's a
very [ __ ] up situation
but because he gets to live in the
protection of his circle and he has to
keep doing this over and over because
nobody's gonna stop him he's in a bubble
and he's in a small little bubble and
then people kind of feed off that type
of energy it's very hard for somebody
step out of the comfort zone and tell a
friend hey you're being [ __ ] up right
right and so because of that these
situations sometimes have to happen
right yeah I even say it with some of
the riots um I don't agree with the rise
obviously but I've said on this podcast
before it's peaceful protesting I really
do believe in it I do think it works but
how would the megaphone of this event
have happened in such grandeur in such a
big way if these rights didn't happen
right cuz then like oh I think these
people are pissed you know yeah because
the peaceful protesting has happened so
many times before it happened earlier
with falando Castille it happened
earlier with a bunch of situations right
I can't even name it and everybody was
up in arms we went to these protests I
went to these protests very peacefully
one month later it all died yeah this is
the longest that it's lasted mm-hmm
right and it's still going on slow down
and even when you go on social media
it's a good style I know some people
will like are tired of it or whatever
but when you go on social media and you
still see these posts and people kind of
still hammering about all these things
like the Brianna Taylor stuff and and
the Elijah McClain does last time yes
yeah then you see it and it's like it's
to me I'm like okay good people are
still talking about this because nothing
has happened yet and this like the fact
that the Brianna
one is so crazy because that's it's it
is same because when you when you read
it I'm just factually like did what
happened you're like no [ __ ] way this
happened yeah like how did this happen
yeah they they went into this girl's
house they shot her while she was
sleeping or something like that right
though it was so they didn't have a
warrant for an arrest right they were
cops that weren't dressed as [ __ ]
cops
yeah they broke into the home started
opening fire so when you break into my
home you're opening fire I have a gun in
my house what are you gonna do right
you're gonna shoot the [ __ ] back alright
yeah
and so they straight up murdered this
girl in her [ __ ] sleep in her bed and
these cops just scratch free they're not
[ __ ] arrested it's like how is that
they said the suspect that they were
trying to find yeah already in custody
exactly is what the [ __ ] yeah things
those instant like arrests like that but
there's the police haven't been held
accountable for all exact look at robbed
dude they've been they've been out of
hand for a long [ __ ] time so it is
like the protesters are great I think
the ryona see wasn't looting is
obviously not the right way to go about
it but I wasn't mad at a I understood
like you're I'm mad no one's listening
throw a rock through this goddamn window
you know it is not the right thing to do
but I've been mad before and punched a
wall yeah that's not the right thing to
do either but I've done that and I get
it it's new bid it I hit it and I don't
keep [ __ ] hittin the wall and try to
break it down that's the thing when when
you're on the outside looking in at
another population that's going through
something like this it's like you have
to come with it you have to come to the
table with some empathy you have to
understand that like yeah obviously
there's not the right way to do it but
can you blame can you understand what
can you probably understand because the
order of importance sometimes gets
messed up right and I had a I had a
buddy who I was reading on his Twitter
and he put he put up a pole and it was a
phrase of like hey do you believe he was
like which one's right or wrong right
it's uh black claw is like hey this [ __ ]
sucks black lives matter black lives
matter but these riots are wrong or do
you say these riots are wrong or black
lives matter which one do you choose
a lot of people chose the first right
but that's the wrong answer okay it
should be these riots are wrong but
black lives matter because it shows the
order of importance of what you're
focused on yeah
you're focused on there's this
destruction that happened in this area
all right versus what the movement is
actually exactly and so it's just it's
just kind of [ __ ] up right because we
have conversations about and Tifa we
have like these random Hooters and right
they have nothing to do with BLM just
[ __ ] [ __ ] up right and a lot of these
people are a bunch of couch surfers who
haven't even been to a [ __ ] protest
to see what's going on and they want to
weigh in on an opinion about it yeah
unless you've been there you don't know
what's up or they're not spending time
in these communities yeah you're not
even a part of these communities you
never even that's what I'm saying it's
like a lot of the opinions that people
have had about the situation was
everybody's allowed to have an opinion
but it's like if I ask them sometimes I
you have a black friend they're like oh
yeah I know black people know do you
have a friend that's close to you that's
that's a black American black person
most likely it's no right it's like you
know of black people I mean you might
have it a black acquaintance yeah but
you're not really close to that culture
right and you would do the same thing
for anybody of Asian culture too it's
like you wouldn't make an Asian joke
about [ __ ] if you didn't know an Asian
person you don't understand the nuance
behind it right but sometimes like
people get that freebie with black
culture just because it's been around in
America for a long time you know I know
of a black person doesn't mean you
understand black culture and that's not
you understand what they go through
right so sometimes like in these in this
platform people go what do you think
about it David I'm like what I say about
it only matters I think about ten ten
maybe five percent yeah because I'm not
a part of that community right when I
could speak up about it but if you want
to know about black culture don't ask a
[ __ ] asian guy that owned a plane use
the plastic don't ask me you're asking
the wrong person and that's your that's
the problem
I like your head's at but we got to get
you to the right sources I'm not a black
guy and he goes I can't why I'm scared I
just got your ass yes sure no tell me
the other guy Danny Danny Matt the
Mathieson what is it oh yeah the guy
from that Sunday show not Kelso what's
his name on the show uh hi hi and it's
so funny he looks like a rapist it's
like those creepy vibes - yeah and he's
just like he always plays like the cool
guy I'm her my sister she met him at
like uh they did like a live taping or
something and she was like everybody was
so nice except for Danny Masterson he
was a total [ __ ] douche bag really
yeah she was like [ __ ] that guy
and then you know I've heard others well
the fact that he came out and said will
they found out that he was being charged
for like raping three different women
it's like I wasn't really surprised I
saw that I don't know but that just mean
that just the just stop vibes I don't
know anything weird I fail to understand
why there has to be some kind of weird
connection with some of these Hollywood
people it's a power thing yeah like to
sexually assault somebody is definitely
a power high like yeah they want to take
something from these women that they
wouldn't normally get if it wasn't by
force
right and that's it's so [ __ ] up I
can't wrap my [ __ ] head around just
like what's the appeal appeal explain
that to me like you're ever hang out
with somebody that doesn't want to be
around you worse feeling ever imagine
forcing yourself on that person it's
like oh dude like obviously it's you
know don't compare to that but it's just
like in the grand scheme of things I
don't know why you know I don't know
that I think we'll understand yeah but
yeah it's it's a it's a year [ __ ] up
in the head dude like you want that
power like and they don't like you while
you're having like that's I mean I've
heard of a lot of just yeah cuz I don't
I don't know of these people and I don't
know what it is about I mean obviously
if you're a victim of this stuff it's
hard to kind of say the name of the
person who affected you that way but
I've I've even heard this story from a
person who so as an actor she was
nothing happened right
but because nothing happened like her
whole career she felt like her whole
career started to derail like a lot of
casting calls wouldn't come in anymore
certain certain casting people
unfollowed her on Instagram Wow you know
is because all of that stuff that she
received was connected through this this
person and so because that person was a
source for everything like she got
dropped by her management and obviously
there's no like proof of this yeah but
because of the relationship that she had
with this person
it's pretty clear I'm pretty evident
right it's like oh we're not gonna hook
up we're not there's nothing romantic
happening between us so all of a sudden
my manager
Wow sudden my you know Allison I'm not
getting any casting calls anymore and
things get a little awkward right and so
she has to pick up from these pieces
there isn't any evidence or anything
else like that and it's hard you know
and I always tell people to like number
one if somebody's approaching you
especially in this industry if any of
you out there getting this industry
right people promised you the world and
everything in it yeah you never in life
specifically in this [ __ ] industry
nothing comes without a price right it's
sad that's just how it is you see
somebody whether you're a guy or girl
actor whatever right and somebody come
is like y'all want to put you in all
this other [ __ ] bla bla bla bla bla
entertain it but understand that people
always expect something in return I'm
not just saying I'm not just talking
about sexually I'm talking about
something else
yeah right and if you're going into
these like situations thinking that
somebody doesn't want something from you
you are at a huge disadvantage right I
expect somebody when they say hey man
I'm gonna make you like bah blah blah
the biggest are cool thank you very much
I'm glad you believe in me I wonder what
this person wants and I'll figure that
out yeah keep your wits about you
because this world is so [ __ ] up right
and that's the sad thing about it a lot
of the times too when you guys come into
the city and I think I get really
annoyed when people say like oh people
in LA they're so [ __ ] wack bah bah
bah blah like all they cares about
getting something from you and I look at
that person and say why did you move to
LA feels like because I want to make
connections and I'm like so you're that
person - yeah yeah you're so you're the
difference between you and that other
person that you don't like is that
they're self-aware that they came here
to take something you're not right right
so you're actually not playing the game
that you came here for you're [ __ ] up
you're losing already poopoo in it you
know yeah sitting on your high horse
exactly thank you very much you're the
exact same person who came into the city
to develop these connections and then
because it's not going your way you're
like I [ __ ] hate people in LA yeah
it's like you are those people the
reason why you went to that brunch was
so you can get connected with these
other human beings and whatever project
didn't work out and now you're like [ __ ]
this person they're not hitting me up
but what was the reason why you
connected with that person in the first
place exactly because you want to either
a role or you wanted something else from
it now next time that you go in these
situations just be a little smart and
expect something better
it's like cool you want to give this
real cool let's chat up don't talk them
over the phone you know have these like
conversations that a little more cut off
a little more 16 be smart about your
[ __ ] I'm not saying stuff that's right
or wrong I'm saying that this world is
[ __ ] up this industry is [ __ ] up so
be better be smarter and [ __ ] those
people over have the understanding
because it probably changes everything
for you be real about it you know by the
way the situation I'm talking about -
like similar situations have happened to
both male and female and Micah's
situation from when I hear these stories
she's actually happened to more male
actors than it has to my female factor
yeah it's crazy huh you would never
think that [ __ ] but it's happened to a
lot of my male actor friends where they
they get hit on by an exec and they kind
of turn turn it away and then
opportunities disappear for like a year
and they have to they have to climb
their way back up so crazy it's insane
that's why that's why why do you think a
lot of these actors and creatives they
start going into YouTube right they
start going into these platforms where
you're allowed to create for yourself
see the reason why YouTube as a platform
worked really well for people like me
who are creators is because there was no
more red tape you can't tell me I can't
create something because you have an
avenue for it to be released somewhere I
could release it tomorrow on YouTube and
develop my own fan base you're gonna
examine or not it's up to the crowd it's
up to the viewers to decide whether I
choose whether I become famous or
recognized for my work why there's
somebody pushing me because that even
happens with record sales right so
sometimes you guys wonder when you guys
hear a record sales site you know this
song is hot trash this person it's not
that great why is it so popular well
it's because people pull strings in the
background they pay these radios lately
yo put this track on put this track on
they had these connects to make these
artists blow up politicking everything
that's based on politics YouTube's not
so much right a little bit yeah you know
because now like youtubers will connect
with each other's like yo let's create
this fake story where I sat on this
grape and and went up my ass and it came
out my mouth we'll call it the great
grape of Italy that'll be the title of
this [ __ ] video right that's what
this whole YouTube space is man it's so
weird there was a point in YouTube where
people are doing fake drama there was a
guy that did I draw a fake video about I
think like his girlfriend killing
herself or some [ __ ] can't come back
from that though huh
there's some weird [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
right now a lot of youtubers are getting
out it out and there people are trying
to quote-unquote cancel them because of
the past behaviors there's a girl named
I think her situations a little weird a
lot of people actually defending her but
her name is jenna Marbles yeah mm-hmm
she's one of those original creators if
you guys see these videos online where's
that color here that white figure yeah
she was a go-go dancer before a really
goofy goofy girl her gogo - yeah she was
a go-go dancer before Wow so she used to
do these videos for it was like what
guys thinks Pink's versus girl things
right so she was like an innovator of
that format to do all the funny voices
dude so she was an innovator of that
[ __ ] obviously a lot of people bit that
they took it to their own and you know
she like people do this why people do
exactly exactly so she was one of those
people and till this day I think she
gets like 3 to 4 million views per video
and it's just heard just petting her dog
you cook that's how strong her fandom is
crazy like I just want her back - a few
of her videos and it was her just like
this is my dog I gave him a new treat
let's see how he likes it abused 4
million views then I went into my shower
with my clothes on and I turn it on all
the way that's all you got the dog bill
right that's right so I could cry with
the dog by the way I shower with my eyes
open with shampoo streaming in it for
example on top just crying but she put
out a video doing an apology video
because I guess back in the day she did
this video where it looked like she was
doing blackface and I guess like when
fans were explained it wasn't really
blackface it was it was something else
but a lot of people flamed her for his
brown face but something like that maybe
goop face that's cool I want somebody do
that maybe crazy just tape your eyes
back and then beat your kids succeeding
at anything in life oh yeah Patrick's
gonna be the first one to do [ __ ] face
he's gonna bring it back bring it back
check his Instagram feeds gonna come out
next weekend yeah she did like a 40
minute
apology video starts crying and she's
like I'm gonna quit YouTube from here on
out because she couldn't take the
pressure of the negative pressure so
it's like you know these youtubers are
getting cancelled now there's another
dude named Shane Dawson
I guess he did blackface a while ago her
was I don't know why it's like clearly
this isn't like a bad area you know
they've landmine well just do this if
you're my person or you know we'll start
there we'll start there if you're first
let's not do that not by the makeup and
let's just not put it yeah and if you're
dawson fan you can go ahead and correct
me if i'm wrong i my but this is just
what I read in you know I'm glancing at
this this is I'm not a new source but
people are asking for him to be canceled
and I saw multiple times on Twitter
because of a video where he did
blackface and they're also saying that
he's also a pedophile
like this whole pedophilia thing going
on which I don't understand yeah right
and I don't have anything and you know
what I heard I heard that bull hates my
guts
busy Oh celebrity boxing match wait what
is Shane Dawson dude this guy I hear the
name he he does like these really really
fantastic like grade-a YouTube
documentary are you being sarcastic I
like he interviews some high profile
people like Jake Paul and he does like
an hour-long documentary I gotta tell
you man you find out great things Wow
and he is amazing yeah but he used to do
he used to do comedy videos and stuff
like that I think I think he think he
was funny though did you think Shane
Dawson was can I tell you something I
have never left so hard in my life
are you being sarcastic again let me
tell you something he Dave Chappelle
might not have good Johnny Wow that he's
that funny dude Shawn Damian is John my
face is one of my favorite okay this is
what it is so I I did this I did this
video back in the day talking about
explaining how I got into YouTube back
in the day right so I got into YouTube
well first of all I knew about YouTube
because I used to watch Korean dramas on
their [ __ ] and then learn how to like
fix my car all right I didn't know that
you could upload content and make comedy
I didn't know I could be a content
creator for you to write so when I found
that out I found out through this uh
this sociology class it was a sociology
was a class of new media
a the example that the professor put up
was a video of Sean Damien so yes I was
like Sean right and so when he put this
video up I said I was like wow this guy
is a comic and he's really popular on
YouTube on sidewalks guy [ __ ] sucks
Channel right and that was the joke that
I told right so he heard about this I
was like kind of like your [ __ ] David so
like he why's he talking [ __ ] about me
and the reason why I said that I was
using this story number one I was
telling a joke
yeah number two I use an example of how
when I was younger in order for me as a
comic I would like try to [ __ ] on other
people's work just to hide my own
insecurities that was the purpose of the
story yeah right it wasn't to say I
hated his [ __ ] yeah but I think he only
heard that part and he was like [ __ ]
this guy yeah like yo bro I just say
your [ __ ] was trashy I think that I do
but that wasn't the point of the story
I've seen like a video of him watching
that content creator Shonda Mian sucks
he's like turned off the video you watch
the rest of her that's all hey man you
probably like me cuz I wasn't the under
the age of 18 so so what so what so what
are the allegations on the pedophile
stuff no I'm interested now hope
somebody everybody's been sending me
this link right now so I got a bunch of
people are DMing it to me like a part of
me doesn't even want to read it like up
but I let me read it let me let me see
cuz dude you're doing blackface you're
getting accused of being a pedophile you
know yeah and at the end of the day the
reason why I don't wanna I'm not gonna
put my two cents in yeah because I don't
know yeah right but do it anyway though
but people are cuz cuz he hates you
because he didn't watch the rest you're
a men let me tell you Shane unless
you're a pal you're into young children
I don't hate you I can dislike your
content like that's okay there's a lot
of people it's my personal friends hate
my comedy yeah right we're not friends
anymore I don't talk to my friends back
at home they don't listen to my podcast
they don't they don't listen to any of
my [ __ ] right they just know that I'm
doing my thing and they move on some
people don't even find me funny they
actually find me highly offensive but
we're still friends able you love
they hate it because I'm tell stories
about them they're like why the [ __ ] did
you tell the story about the innocent
eight I didn't say your [ __ ] name
right Jamie no Danny no much [ __ ] No
one of my friends a Saturday but one of
my friends cracked me up because I told
the story cuz the story of the innocent
eight and I was saying like in high
school how they [ __ ] created this
group it was like a aim group right and
it was like all the innocent eight every
uh every single one of them had their
innocent tag whatever innocent Angela
innocent Rebecca
lovable groups like that huh they love
their cliques so a bunch of the boys
started making fun of them and they're
like I then where they evolution eight
they split into like the angry fours
because so amongst each other or against
the evolution the girls split the eights
lead to four and four and it all started
from a single argument about so that
some of the girls of the innocent eight
for them went to the mall without the
other in a they went to Claire's had a
[ __ ] blast without them got their
[ __ ] pierced or whatever and they came
back and they're like yellow stuff so
ain't you [ __ ] it how come they're
other yeah I thought we were the
innocent eight and you [ __ ] divided
it by to mass and then they're like what
[ __ ] happened why didn't you do that
they're like and [ __ ] started to come
out they're like well why are you being
so sensitive [ __ ] yeah but I'm so up
but I like this person more and then
we're all good and then all their [ __ ]
started coming out when the innocent
eight broke up
oh [ __ ] then one of the innocent eight
dog this [ __ ] was the dopest fight I've
ever seen oh no they find a real fight
this fight so oh cool two of the girls
Helia got into a fistfight right one of
these girls by the way looks like a
bulldog fighter
dog this [ __ ] was so
[ __ ] strong she was like 4 foot 11
and she could beat the [ __ ] out of
anybody like she likes that Mike Tyson
she was crying as I was like 230 pounds
in high school and this [ __ ] usually
gave me piggyback rides
- oh right low center of gravity
listen let me tell you something else so
the one of the girls never got into a
fight in high school at all she's not
violent at all yeah but I think she got
so fed up with what the other innocent
for [ __ ] that after school they started
throwing down low ball what happened
after this the the innocent for actually
left to a different high school oh
that's like we can't take this anymore
we're gone Wow more of them all for them
move to a different high schools it's
like a Netflix show dude yeah so what in
this high school in sigh man dude and
that fight the craziest thing the
Bulldog the Bulldog [ __ ] started a
town stopping this [ __ ] out of one of
the girls head oh boy I've never seen
have you ever seen somebody trying to
take out a [ __ ] napkin fire on the
floor
she started stomping the [ __ ] out of
this girl's face just bow-bow bow-bow I
was shocked and that is the story of the
innocent eight and I got a DM saying why
did you tell that they don't know that
was the end of it well she got a sign up
overlay she was on the Thunder clapping
[Laughter]
hi baby
[Applause]
so the evolution Bay broke up well some
of them they kind of went about their
own ways because you know everybody
nothing no drama though so do you guys
that meeting still or like actually our
high school friends still meet up every
every Thanksgiving everything every
Christmas within eight as well
no the innocent eight split up and and
the funny thing is the innocent for that
we kept in our high school that didn't
move away that group split so now I'm
thinking I sided with the evil group
because the other innocent for
apparently I here are still together
Oh
the righteous ones they were they were
the ones that got their face stomped in
it brought them closer together as a
team especially when the girl's face
look like a Picasso painting we gotta
help when that one girl was in some
thought did the other innocent three
help I think it was so one of the door
it was supposed to be a one-on-one fight
and it was right next to the school
office two out in the parking lot and it
was supposed to be a one-on-one fight
but the Bulldog was like I gotta get my
licks in it she went Bao Bao she led
with this how do you lead with the other
girl already she already took the other
girl down and by that point that one
girl was on the floor and Bulldog came
in and started stomping her face all
mine I'm all about honorable one-on-ones
but if you're a 411 girl and you can
give a dude that's 230 pounds of
piggyback right you jump too much power
she's the juggernaut and especially
what's the average what like 16 110
pounds that's gonna take your pound all
the innocent for strength training
strong enough to handle that and and I
you jump she was a Vietnamese refugee so
you know she looked at me she was like
hey you know what you the same size as
my [ __ ] uh was a cow at home that's
one of the best like most subtle
Vietnamese accents I mean I wrote would
do it nummy a whole time in yeah that's
pretty good because when people do
usually do the Vietnamese accent they go
way over the top and you know simple
I used to bug in cuz Sacramento has a
bunch of enemies people a lot of my
friends are Vietnamese I I don't even
know I could do the accent just because
I heard it so often it's like the most
easiest thing ever but one of the
funniest things I ever saw there's just
a market out in Sacramento that's a
Vietnamese market when you don't know a
language and you try to curse in it you
have to understand when you used the
word [ __ ] properly right so I was at
this market and that was specifically
pick up some groceries for my mom and
this dude was coming out of a parking
lot his large black man and as he was
coming out there's been amis dude didn't
see and he just started backing out I
almost hit his car
so the Duke comes out big old black Duke
comes out and she goes and I [ __ ] you
not I'm not making this [ __ ] up he goes
he broke what the [ __ ] watch where the
[ __ ] you're going this dude like this
five foot two Vietnamese man comes out
right he goes hey [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was like I've never heard
somebody string those curse words
together before he goes you want me to
[ __ ] you now [ __ ] and this dude was like
what what he goes yeah I [ __ ] you now
huh yeah you want to [ __ ] down bro you
don't know what he won that battle the
guy went right back into [ __ ] yeah you
want to you want this [ __ ] big yeah
you want the missionary style you want
the dirty sanchez dude yeah you want
this right now huh I spread the butt
cheeks
you're exactly psychological warfare so
underrated like I got a pink thong on
[ __ ] and he's like what and then
you land that right hand videos like
they go to like the hood or whatever and
they they are they try to pick fights
with fools I mean just get naked those
guys the brother not playing that share
they're out dude oh yeah a hundred not
playing that this'll never works
I know our dude you absolutely don't
wanna you I do the thing that you do now
where I just stay up really late and I
just like I sleep now that I know a lot
we switched kind of roles a little bit
how late you staying up to last night I
went to bed around like 1:30 working on
conspiracy no I you know what I was
watching I just usually I'm like
watching like fights
that's all that's what I usually watch
like late at night but sometimes I are
you gonna get get into a fight this year
or not get into a fight are you gonna
look
fight this year no dude I want you to
fight so bad no I just want one
you can't fighting when I met you I want
you to fight one time while I know we're
friends hey no unless you want to see me
lose I want you to fight make this
[ __ ] good dude that's what I'm say
it's really good man so like what's up
with you guys like what are you guys up
to these days that was the worst
transition ever walking you don't want
to do one more fight cuz I just I just
don't have any boat please dude why
don't I tell you something honest you
would [ __ ] somebody up for sure when we
when we spar right he'll say yeah just
don't every time we said we're supposed
to Train he goes we're probably Sparta
day I'm like he wants to fight somebody
the next thing you know my [ __ ] leg
is welted up by right you can't beat up
your pupil I don't know I don't know
more than you teach me I pick you up bro
you were you're the one that punched him
in the face multiple times and you hit
hard
I do not punch him in the face this guy
just beats me up and he just goes good
session right you're you're painting a
wrong picture rock without what's wrong
with media dude this is what it is right
here no give a guy like this a platform
and he lies to your faces dude I'm
taking a s--t I want you to just do one
more amateur fight no dude just won a
[ __ ] we're good you do really do I
think he's probably better now than he
was when he was fighting before sure
yeah no I'm just you gotta you gotta
have some hate in your heart all the
time well there's a fighter I know that
wants to fight you right now and he said
your mom is a not nice person Wow what
he said that your mom getting fired up
due to you he didn't mention anything
about the c-section no he didn't say
anything about that what's on book is he
in the evolution seven he's also part of
the evolution set oh that's pretty cool
what would it take for you to get into
one more fight just one more fight he
has a daughter now is different he
actually has responsibilities you on the
other hand are a piece of [ __ ] yeah so
if I have a kid I'll be all good
yeah but you don't have a kid like
sometimes I kind of do want to I think
about it I might I'd be nice but then
it's like a lot of training and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] yeah I'm just being lazy here's
the thing about fighting it's like it's
not something you just hop in and hop
out you do have to be on you got to be
all in and you got to be like if you're
gonna fight I feel like you have to be
training like year-round and I'm not
really deep right
running yeah but you could I mean it
just depends on your age do you feel
like you want to fight now I don't have
a niche at all I've known it spar like I
want to train and I want to train with
like my buddies and sighs I need that
but like to go out there and compete I'm
not really like it kind of like that it
doesn't really do anything for me you
know just one look just what I'll give
you a hundred dollars a solid honey
bitching 20 bucks I could really $100
boy so here's the thing okay so we do
120 that's perfect because then I'll
about like two hundred dollars more on
my medicals and everything else after
that okay how about this if I gave you a
thousand dollars do an amateur fight no
I wouldn't do
mm ooh - jeez
I will give you tooth is a this I would
no I wouldn't take money from you that's
it it's not coming from me it's coming
from the evolution seven races that you
guys that's right dollars and a copy of
super smash bros that's a lifetime joy
dlc included or are you going to take it
or not no I'm not no I'm not I'm not
down a fight dude ten thousand dollars
Wow Wow ten thousand dollars from where
don't worry about these lips don't you
tell work I'm not I wouldn't put you
through that
I wouldn't want you to do that so I
would fight for ten G's for sure someone
was like I'll give you $10,000 yeah say
you would fight for tell I was fine for
10 G's Wow fine I just don't want ten
minutes I don't want to fight if you
were to give me money I wouldn't take it
from you that's how I feel about Wow so
once you go [ __ ] yourself oh my god man
I saw
and well Alex that he wants to fight but
this will never trace yeah he's on
Twitter right now that dude he's all
about scratched me the [ __ ] up dude this
school always does his [ __ ] where he
goes a dog you don't even know I'm about
to be on this meal prep as he's eating
carne asada fries in front of me every
time he says he's about to lose weight
he's eating the most unhealthy food and
shoving it down his throat like that
Seagal that ate that rat [ __ ] it's
always like cuz he wants to get into a
fight is he gonna yeah I think so hard
but it's also like priorities change you
know and I think that's the biggest
thing like I'm like oh I mean this when
I say like when you're fighting it's a
really good idea to have your soul focus
on just fighting yes sure as soon as you
have your mind on anything else it's
it's real really hurt I mean it's like
it's you can't play this [ __ ] what about
and what about one of those what do you
call that the what do you call it the
PKB kickboxing [ __ ]
what's that point kickboxing yeah point
kickboxing I don't know Brian huh cuz
it's like what's the point one back
exactly exactly you know but I think
like maybe down the line but probably
not oh look at that I just wanna I know
he has a feel you feel it I know you do
man
don't be limit I don't know I feel fine
a hundred percent you do now you feel it
like three percent maybe I seen the
anger in your heart some [ __ ]
that guy from knocking your contacts
though saw the angry heart when I first
one of the first times that you told the
story before it it's like it doesn't
make me happy at all cuz I don't
remember the story at all I feel like
that's the you're full of [ __ ] when this
[ __ ] when this little sparks sparse
Ricky it's like oh yeah I'm like what is
going on are you Fred why do you like we
beat the [ __ ] out of each other you know
how it is I'm like oh look at this nice
sparring session oh seven head kicks
interesting well you know I'm trying to
kick his body but he's like that no you
guys are just kicking each other in the
face
like none other yeah but that's what
happens when you train with fighters you
know like you train with other fighters
like they're not gonna Pro fighters do
go kind of hard yeah well it's like if
they have to they have to like when you
train even with some how mature fighters
like you understand that there's a
different speed and a different level to
it because they're their intent is very
different than well it is no different
you know when uh whatever bill came in
I'm like oh he's sparring it with a
different intent than me exactly I'm
trying to play patty cakes and he just
hit me when we trim apart we're [ __ ]
around we're having fun you know but
then when you train with a guy that's
like oh I want to fight and my intention
is to fight the flip is swifter because
I could see for him because I recorded
our little sparring session I was like
oh yeah I have no intent to hit him yeah
I mean and he has an intent to hit me
yes thank you that you could tell in my
body language I'm just like he's like
jab jab jab cross body and I'm like dude
you know I don't fight back like what
are you doing yeah yeah pros go hard I
mean that's what they're supposed to do
but it's also too like it you should
recognize who you're sparring it's a
mindset thing it's a mindset I'm not
used to goods we don't spar like that so
I don't know what that feels like and
then when he was hitting me in the face
I was like he's trying to hit me he's
really trying to hit me this guy trained
like that like we trained like super
hard-nosed you know I feel like not a
lot of people would want to tell folks
would not want to train 100% you gotta
like ease people into it something's
gonna be Mike Perry all day dude no
corner no coach no nothing my Perry's
crazy [ __ ] ass
he lost his mind right he feels I he's
been lying he beat my if he beats Mickey
gall that'll be [ __ ] insane I don't
know Mickey call personally but as a
fighter I'm not a big fan of his mm-hmm
but if he loses the Mickey gall and
Mickey gall hasn't been doing that great
he lost the Diego Sanchez yeah so it's
like if if
[ __ ] Mike Perry who's ranked 32 with
the record of six or six says he is the
best fighter in the world yeah not only
did he lose to Diego Sanchez but he lost
of Diego Sanchez with that one guy in
his corner the [ __ ] Joshua oh [ __ ]
yeah me and or Never exactly oh oh is
that the weird whatever happened with
that I heard that dude was saying some
weird [ __ ] about bro he was separably
what he was saying all the ways I see
[ __ ] nah I'm not even gonna [ __ ] yeah
I can't have you got checked by Errol
hewan II airhorn was talking all the
people who had [ __ ] checked by Erika
Lonnie has probably more martial arts
experience than this [ __ ] guy but was
he like a guru yeah he's just one of
those guys that does like oh yeah you
can't pass this force field type of [ __ ]
you know kind of like one of those guys
you know but you get a lot of those guys
in the space and the martial arts world
oh yeah
they think they're [ __ ] don't stink cuz
Mike Perry when I saw some of his videos
you guys know who Mike Perry as Mike
Perry is a is a welterweight right he's
a welterweight fighter he's ranked
number 32 the guy is six is six which
means six losses weight he's ranked
number 33 he's ranked number 32 I
checked it yesterday or some [ __ ] he's
pretty [ __ ] low damn he's down it was
up there because I remember a couple
like three years ago three years ago he
was like oh man
Mike Perry you gotta watch out for this
he is dangerous I know or he has the
potential but I don't know what the [ __ ]
I feel like he's got some tough match
he's very erratic because he's a brawler
so I think like when he comes in and
he's just going at you full force
he's either he knocks you out or he's
he's gonna lose to a technician and
that's what happened with though with
the last person he fought Jeff Neil
Jeff Neil that was a matter feels
amazing yeah this guy he no one really
talks about him in the welterweight
division but he's like he just came
started this one yeah but like the wins
that he has over people and the way he
beat people it's like yeah you know like
a lot of vicious knockouts who else did
he knock out besides Perry I can't
remember one other big name that he
knocked out where I was like oh [ __ ] he
knocked him out he's a technician so
when you have a you know somebody like
Jeff Neil go against a [ __ ] Mike
Perry it's like that's the worst matchup
ever and then he got knocked the [ __ ]
out really damn dad and I'm tombow he
took a knee from Vincent De Luca and he
was still awake so he was out right he
was out yeah yeah it was funny listening
to talk he goes look I'm six to six
right now you know he always like
elongate his words I'm six to six right
now I feel like I'm the best fighter in
the world
I got these people in my corner he's
yelling like throw an elbow like dog
like they can hear you I don't need that
you're blowing on my spot he's like he
goes but I'm six and six I'm ranked
whatever you know I know I got knocked
out two times in the first round by
people who caught me slipping but on the
bed
spider in the world I'm like you don't
know how to make argument for even I
believe it but he's also a dude that
like he goes on Instagram live and stuff
and people get mad at him because he
drops the n-bomb a lot but he's like I'm
2% African I did my [ __ ] test I found
out I'm 2% African so I could say this
2% African Turkish bro but he's he's fun
to watch his 22 year old girlfriend is
gonna coach him what she's gonna be
ringside and he was saying that she has
like wrestling experience I hope he wins
though I hope he wins just so he could
be like you know I don't need none of
that [ __ ] I'm sure he needs to make that
just in a gay gay she adjustments like
that brawler style but like he gets like
controlled chaos kind of thing that
would work at least Jessy she listens
yeah yeah yeah my first two wild it's
too much oh it's weird because we just
watched just engage she just beat the
[ __ ] he gave so much respect to Trevor
Whitman which literally his advice is
why he won the fight right and then you
have my parry on the other side who goes
you don't need a coach it's like the
reason why I want to watch this fight so
bad if you're here what you're gonna
hear the conversation better Dan hooker
and Poyet oh yeah it's tomorrow it's
gonna be [ __ ] hilarious okay baby
this is what you're gonna do if you
don't win you're not gonna get [ __ ] for
two weeks okay yeah I got you imma imma
go out and I'm fun I'm finna nochmal
that's a good Mike Perry impression of
Rome I listen to him a lot I was
listening to one of his interviews where
I came over here but he was saying like
oh yeah I'm not really training and I'm
just like no matting around going in
different gyms hell yeah and I'm like
yeah I hope that works out for you god I
even watched his sparring footage i
watch his MIT work I'm waiting for
something to be like this guy's
next-level [ __ ]
but even in his sparring sessions he's
getting pieced up is he really
yeah he's getting pieced up and then he
starts putting on that aggressive [ __ ]
and that's when he starts winning the
sparring sessions but it's like well you
just amped it up and it's not on the
same level as what your spine hard damn
dude you know who impressed me was the
guy that beat I think it was on the gay
chief Ferguson card they gotta beat
Jeremy Stephens Calvin came Calvin who
paid right before that fight cuz I've
been in and out like when I first
started watching UFC I was like
religious about it yeah every single car
now it's like I don't watch all of them
cuz there's so many and I used to watch
all the cards together like when we were
fighting every weekend we go to pats on
every air I never missed [ __ ] but like
now I've since fallen out so this is my
first time seeing that what was the name
again dan and Calvin gentlemen
commentator I was about to say Dan
angleman that's how good I listen that's
time commentator today man woman brother
dude shame is Bingle bomb realtor
extraordinaire but dude that dude
impress the [ __ ] out of me coz he not
only was he technically amazing like how
he knocked out Jeremy Stephens but he
weathered the storm he's not a
punishment that Jeremy's Jeremy [ __ ]
Steve yeah no slouch dude that's true
that dude is a beef that was beautiful
it was how he did it it was amazing
credible and nobody knocks out Jeremy
Stephens like that yeah yeah well it's
not easy that's for sure yeah do it and
the way he did it was like oh my and
Jeremy Stephens in that first round was
giving him trouble Dan yeah he came out
like a [ __ ] bad matchup for everybody
yeah everybody even even Jeremy Stephens
when he once again when he went against
Aldo he was winning yeah until that
amazing body shot was in same booze all
those about to have a good four oh yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah he's like that yeah
who's the favorite in that Peter yeah
Peter yeah by I think he's - 235 no
hammer and sickle to the ring baby
yeah knocked the [ __ ] out of your eye a
favor - yeah the way he knocked him out
oh it was bad just looking at [ __ ]
his face was all [ __ ] up men crazy why
don't you get into one more fight one
more
was I think about guys like Peter Yan
and I'm like yeah no thank you no thank
you
what would do good I bet your beast
I'm not I'm not down to that life you
wouldn't wait wait did you fight that I
fought it was all over the place because
there's a lot of times as an amateur
like people just set up fights where
they can make it so yeah like I fought
one time at 130
I cut 16 pounds in two weeks for that
that was terrible
the word look and then and then I fought
the second one I fought 135 but the guy
that I was that I fought miss weight by
ten pounds borough and the guy that was
coaching him was one of our older
coaches and we're like yo just hit a
stop dog like I'm a wait for this [ __ ]
in this for me man I was overweight and
dude yeah but you know he said through
the fight well I was like we might as
well fight was it it was a my last one
Eric Braganza oh yeah yeah that's what I
want yeah you lost your last but like
you have to fight just cut them down
it's not bobbles finish them the thing
that I've done he did I almost finished
he was dropping some nasty brought
another rage and exercise yeah I was I
was so pissed at the weigh-in this dude
was like standing across he was just
like looking at me like this and on my
head brah like in my head I'm like dog
we're amateurs like who gives a [ __ ]
like yeah there's no promo here like
we're gonna fight two more like we're
gonna fight later tonight like why are
you acting like a little idiot you know
I'll run it back that's the fight I'll
come back for if that fool wants to
fight I'll fight that Braganza organza I
hope you listen to let's take that fight
that's a fight I'll take I'll come back
to that God he was kind of a nice guy
but whatever doesn't matter
well yo I just got the best text ever
right now what my buddy William has just
postponed his wedding until next year
thank you
hey William I didn't want to tell you
this but I wasn't gonna show up
[Laughter]
last minute just to [ __ ] with you don't
you know Matt don't you love when plans
come through like that
I know poster go to something and you
just don't have to go anymore yeah coz
William what the [ __ ] man why would you
reap postpone your wedding for this year
during quarantine right like what's
wrong with you you [ __ ] I love you I
love like one of my closest family I
love you yeah yeah but uh yeah back to
story saw at the way and he was like
dogging me from across the
like the whole time every time I look
over at him he just like it's like
staring at me laughs and then um the sec
and then when we faced off like business
let's take picture ever after the way in
this do like got it up in my face and
it's actually a really funny picture
yeah we're like he's like all the way
right here and I'm like yes and I'm like
looking around and he's you see savant
like it's like a puzzled look on his
face like what the [ __ ] is this we'll do
it but I mean like the whole time he's
like dogging me and kind of like being a
[ __ ] idiot
and then I first almost scared as [ __ ] I
was like god damn this [ __ ] is
like scary like hit he looked like he
was 30 years old here like a Playboy
bunny tattoo on his chest
mmm and he was like a thick little
stocky guy and I look like a bag of bone
yet a Playboy bunny tattoos weird [ __ ]
on a mohawk and she looked rats and I
was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh this
[ __ ] track you me dog yeah but
um as I remember I was warming up I got
like really pissed I was like this
[ __ ] thinks he could do all this
[ __ ] to me and pick on me whatever miles
I'm gonna [ __ ] this fool up there yeah
and I was pissed I was really pissed and
walking out to the fight like like after
this this like rage came out of me that
I didn't think I would have because I
was scared yeah I was variously and I
was like in the first fight where I felt
like nervous I grew the air and um when
I walked out I was just getting madder
and madder and I when I saw him walk to
the cage I was like I'm gonna [ __ ] this
fool up like yeah relief and I've never
felt that way ever usually I'm like all
right we're gonna see what happens yeah
but this time all's I'm gonna [ __ ] this
dude up and right when the bell rang I
was like I'm gonna head kick this
[ __ ] like yeah so I threw a
combination head kicked them like he
blocked it and then he just double like
me put me gives you a page and he was a
lot stronger than me
alas sorry let me hold you down ten
pounds [ __ ] heavier yeah yeah but
then again it's like I should I should
have been able to stop to take downs and
all that stuff but he just held me down
for like two rounds third round
everytime the round came out like the
third round I was like I'm gonna [ __ ]
I have to like knock this blob yeah I
use in this the bond is in the corner
and he's like you gotta knock this
[ __ ] out I was like all right
and I went out and I had kicked them
blocked it took me down again and then I
was like [ __ ] wall and the rounds are
two minutes yeah it's like virtually
nothing it's it's a blink of an eye and
then I remember I was like [ __ ] it I'm
gonna shoot a takedown on them and
wrestling was not my standpoint like my
strong point at all shot a double leg on
them got stuff sat out first time I've
ever done that ever you know and then I
sat out and then I got on top and I just
started pounding this fool out and I was
really close to finishing I thought I
had I thought the ref was gonna stop it
yeah yeah you got him I remember that he
was like it's funny cause like in the
moment like you don't realise what's
kind of happening cuz you're just like
like oh but there's all these like
strategic positions that could have
taken like his legs were open he was
like he wasn't like an open guard I
should have went to full mount
I should I just tried to threaten his
submissions I should have done all those
things but I did it because I was so
worried about trying to knock this
[ __ ] out exactly and at the time
like after re-watching the tape I'm like
[ __ ] I could I could have beat this
[ __ ] and I felt my arms like
give out 4zn yeah and I lost that fight
but you know it
that fight taught me I was like all
right well I gotta start wrestling I
started doing jujitsu and that's when I
started falling more in love and then
you didn't do one more [ __ ] fight
well you know what that's when I got
that's when I started getting injuries
and stuff like that that's when I
started getting like the concussions and
things like that and then I just was
like you know what then and then I
started liking coaching way more and
then it became more of my life and I
walked into his life and he's like Nick
Dunne you're a piece of trash but he's
like Nick Dunne this is gonna be a burly
tattooed Irishman then I came out this
little like a small [ __ ] yeah a
little twink [ __ ] this little
[ __ ] [ __ ] monster came up to me and
he was like hey I'm Nick Dunne and I'm
like get the [ __ ] out of your chinko and
that's all we did yeah 1 2 1 2 1 2
switch 1 2 whoa whoa
oh my god that's such a good person so
angry Metta Moses guy [ __ ] duped me
what's your offer what's your real last
name do it's done okay alright mr. Chang
yeah you later
whatever winged hop let's [ __ ] do
this guy damn we were talking about our
old the old video clips would be like
back in then I used to record myself and
I remember when I first recorded myself
was like god these hands are so fast
always somebody will catch the videos
like slow-mo with the speed of the video
man a lot better though like even though
the clips I see you hit in the back now
am i it doesn't look that like that when
I spar though like well it's always
harder in person like yeah it just takes
practice um you're not sparring everyday
you know it means like you know in time
is in time I don't have much time now
it's like the first year though I was
really really into it I got super into
it and then after a while it started to
hurt like oh we're sorry it becomes a
grind you know because what it is that's
what it's like that's why you really
have to love this [ __ ] man like if
you're not about that fight life and you
think you could just do this part-time
and you think it's just all fun and
games and you plan on competing that's
when [ __ ] find out like you're
not really about this life and you get
[ __ ] up man you get hurt it's hard
it's definitely the the the rounds and
repetition is the biggest thing because
you can't see those improvements until
you stop and you try to come back
exactly right and it's like oh [ __ ] that
those every day week that every week
sparring thing helped a lot oh yeah you
don't register it until you stop doing
it right and I'm like oh I'm awkward
again I can't see openings right oh this
is this is this is timings our fireman
is off yeah it's not like riding a bike
you can just come back to it you know
yeah there's no you know how like a
rhythm I'm like oh this is weird I don't
know what I don't know my feet position
or anything like that thinking too much
way too much man especially when we we
went to go train in a closed place and
then we're just like sparring oh I can't
see anything
this is trouble I don't see anything I'm
like looking for all it's somebody on I
don't see anything happening so lo and
behold I teeth the bottom my foot again
come on baby
I was out
all right that's the David's though
signature injury right now I have
cracked this the bottom of my foot on a
knee twice now [ __ ] beep you keep
somebody boys cuz I just kind of get
lazy and I just throw the foot out
versus yo chambering in in trying to
pierce somebody yeah door from like this
yeah it's like the worst thing ever so
he's at the top of your foot of the
bottom of your foot it's all right so
like I I was out for like damn two three
weeks couldn't I couldn't walk for the
first week damn yeah it was that like my
foot my foot was a balloon yes it was
pretty bad but I feel bad keeping
somebody inspiring because I should
hurts yeah do it
it's the equalizer dude I just kicked
people there's I was supposed to do you
think Jason feels bad we know he doesn't
hit he has teeth the spirit out of me
what is peace are so drastic he has
knocked me down with teeths before where
I just lost the air out of my [ __ ]
that's me harder good he's got gnarly
that's this [ __ ] dude that's his money
shot it's right in yeah I can't read it
either so I'm always trying to he has
assumed it out the way I just can't do
it yeah it doesn't throw it you know
like oh he's just taking it easy and
then he gets you to think about it and
then he hits you with some other [ __ ]
his stupid little [ __ ] combos to my
face did his stupid jab hook body he
always gets that much did you like 18
times with one hand this stupid [ __ ]
Lennox Lewis heck yeah
backwards hat and [ __ ] looking all cool
[ __ ] saying crazy [ __ ] the whole time
[ __ ] thousand miles a minute this is
the only person that'll beat my ass as
he's giving me advice on how not to get
my ass beat there the whole time the
whole time he's not even stop hey when I
hook you in the face black he goes make
sure you keep that Club up
thanks man alright I can't feel my thumb
but cool I'm just talking like Mike
Tyson atha like what's done what am I
supposed to do next
if I come he do with the slip yeah I do
you're really good at impressions you
know you find this information and you
just watch like a bunch of rape
documentaries hey dude I don't hey
that's not what's going on man we talked
about this dirty I just like when
justice
gun is Krista Leah's best friend oh yeah
he is also in a text read I produces
podcast with Delia and the guy from that
70s show yeah yeah I do his podcast and
Jeffrey Epstein you have a new podcast
coming Jeffrey Epstein podcast is gonna
be dropping next Friday
Wow and the title that podcast is I be
touching the resurrection you'll never
find me those allegations are 100% true
that's that's what it's gonna be about
anyway I'm gonna be a great podcast for
you guys love it yeah well guys that
wraps up this episode of the genius
brain [ __ ] yes so bad Thank You rapping
you look like it just like a son of a
[ __ ] you didn't even drink anything of
this lovely liquor before you a new
couch yeah we have some healthy pores so
we have about five more minutes before
we sign off where well you guys could
catch you guys we're on Instagram it's
my name patrick tatia taught right it's
my name dude it's my name dude it's men
you find me on Nick's a year on
Instagram and then we also have our big
mad podcast if you guys want oh yeah we
haven't done this [ __ ] yeah it's been a
little bit it's uh everyone's been kind
of busy but we're gonna we're gonna
release another one next week pass sons
a [ __ ] come on baby see y'all next
time